we're continuing our conversation today
for the entire hour with dr. Peter
Boghossian I want to talk a little bit
Peter about an issue that you've been
speaking about a lot over the last
couple years and this relates to
concerns about some of what's going on
in academia in the United States so I
want to start with a tweet from April of
2016 that you sent where you talked
about gender studies and you said gender
studies is primarily composed of radical
ideologues who view indoctrination as
their primary duty these departments
must be defund defunded I can say least
and good so I want to break down some
aspect of that first is sort of there's
an assertion you make about radical
ideologues how do we define what is a
radical ideologue and then how do you
quantify whether they believe that their
primary duty is indoctrination in other
words how did you source that tweet or
come up with that idea okay so we gotta
take those one at a time so give me give
me your first question you like to pack
a lot of stuff I pack it in yeah and let
you in so how do you define whether a
college professor it particularly one in
Gender Studies is a radical ideologue
how do you figure that out uh well not
just gender studies but anything
infected by post-modernism and Gender
Studies happens to be the most egregious
example that okay you speak you figure
it out because you look at their self
that's an awesome question but I really
hope that if anybody gets people getting
nothing out of that they just listen to
that question and then listen to this
response okay
we know this because when we look at the
an item happy to email you some stuff
about this when we look at the course
descriptions these are not merely
information based courses these are
ideology mills they want people to adopt
specific views about the world about
homosexuality which basically I have as
well by the way but but these are
ideology mills in which the goal is not
to educate from the Latin edge akari to
lead out of a clique if you think about
in terms of Plato's cave you're coming
from a place of Darkness place of life
you are putting beliefs into people and
we know that because not only do we look
at the course descriptions of Gender
Studies any Gender Studies program you
want
I mean literally any and everything but
we can also look at the mission
statement of peer-reviewed journals so
let's not I want to focus because of the
tweet the tweet was about defunding
Gender Studies departments based on
radical ideology yeah what do we do
about that well uh look we can do what I
tried to do which is publish a whole
paper it was a satire on gender studies
to show that that the the emperor has no
clothes we can make this fact available
to parents who are paying tuition for
their students to become indoctrinated
into these insane ideas ok but hold on
Peter Peter I think I think we're let me
slow us down usually you're slowing me
down let me slow down a little bit
uh so in figuring out whether a
professor is a radical ideologue you
said you look at whether the syllabus
includes ideology rather than teaching
or how do you determine that like what
would be an example of a syllabus that
would indicate we're dealing with a
radical island not a syllabus this is
way beyond the syllabus ok it's just a
departments mission statement ok this is
their mission statement and I would look
it up right now but we're live on camera
but this is what they're this isn't me
I want to make crystal clear about that
this is not me saying this this is them
saying this is in their own words what
they want to do they are activists look
how many times the word activism appears
in their course descriptions these
people self-described as activists and
on what basis one well basis should an
academic department be funded or not
well based upon whether or not their
conclusions accord with reality as I
journals I think well I also think we
should you fund theology departments as
well well look ok so there is a broad
spectrum of this at one and you have
theoretical physicists who are positing
ideas about the nature of universe
unified field theory of string theory
all the stuff that I don't understand ok
and the argument has been made that
that's
there's not enough evidence that okay
great but these people aren't claiming
to know this these are not huge look
here's the difference Daniel Dennett
said it best philosophy the discipline
that I'm in when you work in philosophy
you should be doing work of abiding
significance
those are Dennis terms that he uses in a
little paper called a traumatic memory
SS chess with that mess in it the
difference between somebody wasting
their time working on issues of non
abiding significance is it really
doesn't the papers incited it really
doesn't make any difference I think I
heard a lecture in which 80% of papers
and humanities are only cited one time
if at all zero to one times gender
studies and in disciplines infected by
post-modernism are different in that
they are morally motivated so it's not
just that they twiddle their thumbs and
work away on esoteric problems how many
grains of sand and heat and things like
this but they they work to radicalize
and galvanize people into moral ways of
viewing the world and I would argue that
if you look at the madness emanating
from colleges today it can be directly
traced back to post-modernism in general
and Gender Studies instead they are a
hater I guess my question I guess is I
think everything sorry I think they are
solely responsible for intersectionality
the worst plague that's affecting us
right now yeah I mean I've talked about
I've talked about the ways in which
that's problematic but I guess if we
imagine this spectrum that you've talked
about which is theoretical physics on
one side and let's imagine Gender
Studies at the other who decides where
the line is drawn between what is
legitimate for academic departments to
teach and study and what isn't okay in a
if you were to go back 50 years that
question would be easy
you'd say does this stuff pass peer
review does it muster a is are there
lines of literature on this but we can't
do that anymore
it's almost like phrenology like if they
were a discipline you know when they
look the shape of the head and such and
they extrapolate make inferences about
ones
intelligence and race and such right
it's been debug so if we look at what's
happening now in gender studies these
people are making their own journals
admittedly this isn't just the
understudies but you in gender space you
find the worst example yeah we're taught
we can focus on that since it's it's a
good one for us to discuss yeah so you
find people making their own journals
publishing in their own journals
becoming promoted and receiving tenure
because they've promoted in their own
journals but do the same thing I mean
physicists have feel like we're in a
Seinfeld episode dentists have their own
schools physicists have their own
journals and those journals and
publication in those journals is also
used right I guess what I'm trying to
drill down at is how do we effectively
distinguish okay we'll look but the
difference in physics is we can make
assessments about physical phenomena of
the world and those are empirical
questions gender studies is dealing with
moral issues and they're making moral
pronouncements of issues and they're
backing this up by their own invented
corpus of literature and again I'm on
board with most of most of these
conclusions already you get Aryan
treatment of people try to render people
homes I'm on board with that but that is
not the role of an active active edition
that is certainly not the role of an
academic department that makes a mockery
of our institutions because it turns the
peer-review process into a sham and
they'll read the way that it does that
and then I'll get back to your issue of
defunding the way that it does that is
they manufacture they're morally
motivated they manufacture their own
lines of discipline they get promoted
and tenure and when you attempt to call
them out on this this is gets back to
the earlier segment we did about faith
they believe anyway right they're going
to believe in it they here's his example
do we want to defund I don't know give
me example of the discipline do we
wanted to fund engineering well no okay
yeah yeah well because we there are
actual bridges you go in and you learn a
skill about the world is an empirical
skill okay that's got your fixed spot
here's really what I'm wondering if we
can sort of talk this through together
and see if we end up at the same place
are you in agreement that gender is
important to homosapians in other words
when we think about Homo sapiens and the
culture that Homo sapiens live in is
gender relevant I would think of course
it is everything it is okay generally is
there academic value to studying issues
of important to Homo sapiens yeah and I
know where you're going but where I'm
going is where I'm going is it sounds
like you disagree with a lot of what it
the way in which gender studies is being
taught maybe the people that are
teaching it the way in which you believe
maybe there's this closed loop of sort
of credentialing of gender studies
through internal peer review you know
their own journals so to speak but it's
hard for me to make the case based on
what you just said which is gender is a
very relevant element of human society
and that it's important to academically
study issues of importance to human
society based on that alone it's hard
for me to argue there should not be
gender studies departments okay so some
of the best research on gender does not
come from gender studies departments
they come from sociology departments if
you want a rough guide to figure out
whether or not a discipline is
legitimate ask yourself and by
legitimate I mean correlated facts to
external reality ask yourself if the
methodologies they use there are pista
mala jeez if you will are manufactured
or they're not so for example bridge
building to get that to engineering and
and most most disciplines out of
humanities the hard sciences we use the
scientific method if you want to justify
a moral conclusion that you make but you
can't do it you can't reason your way to
it one thing that we see now in
post-modernism disciplines infected by
post-modernism is that they make up
their own methodologies to justify their
conclusions for
example Auto ethnography is a and I
would urge your viewers to google and
look up Auto ethnography because it's
just so crazy Auto ethnography is the
idea that you basically do self
interviews and relate them to the
literature in some way it's your own and
then the the bought the body of
literature on Auto ethnography and the
individual papers coming out about Auto
ethnography will absolutely blow your
mind okay that's better but just just to
keep us laser focused if we can if it
sounds like we're in am in a blurry area
in the sense that you don't like Gender
Studies as taught by Gender Studies
departments but you're conceding that
Gender Studies is important to human
society and there is importance gender
is important and and then I will tell
you something that I find fascinating if
you don't mind gender is important I
look at I think that I think there was
overwhelming evidence that these let me
let me say something I cannot tell you
why this is but I find this to be
absolutely fascinating my wife is an
anthropologist and she has a an MD
that's somewhat beside the point but
when she was in getting another PhD she
met many people working in in
cross-cultural women's issues and I like
the work of these people I'm not going
to tell you the name specifically so I
said to my wife I would like to use this
person at these people as an example of
somebody who's doing really good work on
gender in this particular example and
I'll tell you why I'm not going to give
you specifics in a moment this woman
worked at the intersection of public
health policy and transgender issues and
AIDS it's also some really good stuff
about travesties and Brazil etc so my
wife said well why don't you call her up
and make sure it's okay that you use her
name and I said Bob absolutely someone
wanted to use my name and my work I do
that absolutely so I called her up said
who I was she said oh yeah you know and
and I said like you use her name and she
said no and I said
really and she said no I'm just not
comfortable with that I said okay can
you give me the exam can you please give
me three or four examples of people you
consider to be doing good work in gender
studies or with gender in particular and
she said no and I thought wow that's
really interesting and then I just kind
of wrote it off as an anomaly
I have subsequently asked two additional
people people I respected whose work I
respect if I could maybe I'm too
controversial figure I don't know or if
they could recommend somebody else a
version of what's called snowball
sampling not you know can you recommend
somebody else's work that I can read or
that I can look at and both of those
people said no so there's some that
that's very interesting to me and you
know maybe academic but I think that
there's something in the nature of this
field that is absolutely toxic at its
core so much so that people really don't
want their work subject to any scrutiny
because at base I think they're
pretending I think that they are morally
motivated aisle ideologues and they
realize at its core that the work coming
out of their departments is not based in
reality it is and these are activists
who are masquerading as academic as back
in traditions all right well your your
point of view on that coming through
loud and clear let's pause there with
dr. Peter Magowan more after the break